ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ความเข้าใจเรื่องข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ฉันชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิคด้านการศึกษาที่ IBM
Quantum นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 11 ของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนที่สามใน
unit ที่สาม ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ general formulation ของ quantum information บทเรียนนี้เกี่ยวกับการวัด ซึ่งเป็น
interface ระหว่าง quantum และ classical information เมื่อทำการวัดบนระบบในขณะที่อยู่ใน
quantum state classical information ถูกดึงออกมา เผยให้เห็นบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ quantum state นั้น และโดยทั่วไปเปลี่ยนหรือ
ทำลาย state นั้นในกระบวนการ ใน simplified formulation ของ quantum information ซึ่งพูดถึงใน
unit แรกของซีรีส์ โดยทั่วไปเราจำกัดความสนใจกับ projective measurements รวมถึง
การวัดแบบง่ายที่สุดคือ standard basis measurements อย่างไรก็ตามเป็นไปได้ที่จะ generalize notion ของการวัด
และปรากฏว่ามันมีประโยชน์มาก ในบทเรียนนี้เราจะพูดถึงการวัดในลักษณะทั่วไปอย่างสมบูรณ์
รวมถึงวิธีที่อธิบายในรูปแบบคณิตศาสตร์และวิธีที่เข้ากับ general formulation ของ quantum
information ในช่วงท้ายของบทเรียนเราจะดูแนวคิดพื้นฐานสองอย่างที่เชื่อมโยงกับการวัด ได้แก่ quantum state
discrimination และ quantum state tomography ดังนั้นเริ่มกันเลย นี่คือภาพรวมของ
บทเรียน เช่นเดิม เราจะเริ่มด้วยพื้นฐาน รวมถึงสองวิธีที่ต่างกันแต่เทียบเท่ากันในการ
อธิบายการวัดในรูปแบบคณิตศาสตร์ โดยเฉพาะเราสามารถอธิบายการวัดด้วย collections ของ matrices
และเราสามารถอธิบายเป็น channels ด้วยซึ่งฉันพาดพิงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า เราจะพูดถึง partial
measurements หรือกล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่งการวัดที่ทำบนแค่ส่วนหนึ่งของ compound system ที่ใหญ่กว่า
จากนั้นเราจะไปที่ Naimark's theorem ซึ่งเป็น fact พื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับการวัดที่โดยพื้นฐานบอกว่า
general measurements สามารถ implement ได้เสมอในวิธีง่ายๆ ที่ชวนให้นึกถึง Stinespring
representations ของ channels กล่าวสั้นๆ general measurements สามารถ implement ได้เสมอโดยการ introduce ก่อนซึ่ง
initialized workspace system จากนั้น perform unitary operation และสุดท้าย perform standard basis
measurement บน workspace system ปรากฏว่าพิสูจน์ได้ค่อนข้างง่ายและเราจะเห็นวิธีที่มันดำเนินไป และ
เราจะเห็นวิธีที่เชื่อมต่อกับสิ่งที่เรียกว่า non-destructive measurements ซึ่งฉันจะอธิบาย สุดท้ายในช่วงสุดท้ายของ
บทเรียน เราจะพูดถึง quantum state discrimination และ quantum state tomography เราจะเริ่มด้วย
mathematical descriptions ของการวัด การวัดให้ interface ระหว่าง quantum และ
classical information เมื่อทำการวัดบนระบบในขณะที่อยู่ใน quantum state บางตัว classical information
เกี่ยวกับ quantum state นั้นถูกดึงออกมา นอกจากนี้ quantum state โดยทั่วไปจะเปลี่ยนหรืออาจถูก
ทำลายอย่างสมบูรณ์ ในตอนแรกเราจะโฟกัสที่ destructive measurements ที่เรียกว่า ซึ่ง
quantum state เข้าไปและ classical information เท่านั้นออกมา ดังนั้นไม่มีการระบุ
postmeasurement quantum state ของระบบที่วัด โดย intuitive แล้ว เราสามารถจินตนาการว่า destructive measurement
ทำลายระบบใดก็ตามที่วัด ดังนั้น state ของมันหลังจากการวัดเกิดขึ้นจึงไม่
ถูกระบุ สิ่งนี้ไม่ได้หมายความว่า physical devices ถูกทำลายจริงๆ มันเป็นแค่
mathematical description และมันมีประโยชน์มากเพราะช่วยให้สิ่งต่างๆ เรียบง่ายและโฟกัสที่ mathematical
aspects ที่สำคัญของการวัด มีสองวิธีที่เทียบเท่ากันในการอธิบาย destructive
measurements โดยเฉพาะตามที่ฉันพูดถึงระหว่างภาพรวมของบทเรียน วิธีหนึ่งในการอธิบาย destructive
measurement คือด้วย collection ของ matrices โดยเฉพาะเรามี matrix หนึ่งสำหรับแต่ละ measurement
outcome ที่เป็นไปได้ อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการอธิบาย destructive measurement คือด้วย channel ที่
input คือ state ของระบบใดก็ตามที่กำลังวัด และ output เป็น diagonal density matrix เสมอ ซึ่งเราสามารถ
ตีความเป็น description ของ probability distribution บน measurement outcomes classical ที่เป็นไปได้
สอง descriptions นี้เทียบเท่ากัน และมันมีประโยชน์มากเพราะช่วยให้เราเลือก description ที่สะดวกกว่าใน
สถานการณ์ที่กำหนด เราจะพูดถึง non-destructive measurements ด้วย ซึ่งนอกจาก classical measurement
outcome แล้ว postmeasurement quantum state ของระบบที่วัดก็ถูก
ระบุด้วย non-destructive measurements มีความสำคัญและเกิดขึ้นบ่อย แต่ในแง่หนึ่งพวกมัน
ไม่ fundamental เท่า destructive measurements ในรูปแบบคณิตศาสตร์ โดยเฉพาะปรากฏว่า
non-destructive measurements สามารถอธิบายเป็น compositions ของ channels และ destructive measurements ได้เสมอ และ
เราจะเห็นวิธีที่ทำงานในภายหลังในบทเรียน ตอนนี้ดูว่าการวัดหมายถึง destructive
measurements สามารถอธิบายเป็น collections ของ matrices ได้อย่างไร ตลอดการพูดถึงนี้ สมมติว่า X เป็นระบบที่
กำลังวัด และเพื่อความเรียบง่าย เราจะทำ assumptions สองอย่าง ก่อนอื่นเราสมมติว่า
classical state set ของ X ประกอบด้วย integers ตั้งแต่ 0 ถึง n ลบ 1 สำหรับ positive integer n บางตัว และ
outcomes ที่เป็นไปได้ของการวัดคือ integers ตั้งแต่ 0 ถึง M ลบ 1 อีกครั้งสำหรับ positive integer M บางตัว ไม่
จำเป็นต้องมีความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง n และ M พวกมันเป็น positive integers arbitrary และแน่นอนเราสามารถแทน
sets เหล่านี้ด้วย classical state sets arbitrary ได้ถ้าต้องการ ก่อนอื่นนึกถึงวิธีที่ projective
measurements ทำงาน ซึ่งเราพูดถึงครั้งแรกในบทเรียนที่สามของซีรีส์ จากที่สมมติว่า
measurement outcomes คือ integers ตั้งแต่ 0 ถึง n ลบ 1 เราอธิบาย projective measurement ด้วย collection
ของ projections Pi 0 ถึง Pi M ลบ 1 ที่รวมกันได้ identity matrix และ matrices เหล่านี้ทั้งหมดมี rows และ
columns สอดคล้องกับ classical states ของ X หรือกล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง สิ่งเหล่านี้ล้วนเป็น n คูณ n
matrices ถ้า X อยู่ใน quantum state ที่อธิบายด้วย quantum state vector S แต่ละ measurement outcome ที่เป็นไปได้
a ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ Euclidean norm กำลังสองของ Pi a คูณ
vector S Euclidean norm กำลังสองของ vector ใดๆ เท่ากับ inner product ของ vector
นั้นกับตัวเอง ดังนั้นเราได้ expression ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ และเราสามารถ simplify นิดหน่อย
โดยใช้ fact ที่ว่า Pi a เป็น projection ดังนั้นการคูณกับตัวเองไม่ได้
ทำอะไร และสุดท้ายเราสามารถเขียน expression ที่ได้ในลักษณะที่ต่างออกไปเล็กน้อยโดยใช้ cyclic property
ของ trace อีกครั้งตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ และถ้าไม่ชัดเจนว่าทำไมเราถึงต้องการเขียน expression แบบนี้
คำตอบสั้นๆ คือเราต้องการเข้าใจว่า projective measurements ทำงานอย่างไรสำหรับ density
matrices และโดยเฉพาะโดย linearity เรามีว่าถ้า state ของ X อธิบายด้วย density matrix row แทน
quantum state vector S ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcome a ที่จะปรากฏถูกให้โดย trace ของ projection
Pi a คูณ density matrix row ต้องเป็นเช่นนั้นเพราะตามที่เราเห็น
เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ density matrix ว่าเป็น weighted average ของ pure states เสมอ และถ้าเรา average
ความน่าจะเป็นที่สอดคล้องกัน เราได้ expression นี้เพราะ trace เป็น linear function ดังนั้นนั่นคือ expression ที่เรา
ต้องการ และเราสามารถ clean สิ่งต่างๆ ขึ้นเล็กน้อยเพื่อโฟกัสที่ density
matrices จุดหลักของการทำสิ่งนี้โดยวิธีคือเพื่อสร้าง reference point กับสิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้ไปแล้ว
และเพื่อเห็นว่า description ของ projective measurements นี้จริงๆ แล้วเป็น special case ของ description ที่ general กว่าของการวัดที่เรา
กำลังจะเห็น ดังนั้นสิ่งที่ฉันจะทำตอนนี้คือแทน description นี้ว่า projective measurements ทำงานอย่างไรสำหรับ density matrices
ด้วย description สำหรับ general measurements เพื่อให้เราเข้าใจความสัมพันธ์ และนี่คือ
มัน general measurement ที่ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น projective measurement อธิบายด้วย collection ของ positive semi-definite
matrices p 0 ถึง PM ลบ 1 ที่รวมกันได้ identity และถ้าการวัดนี้ทำบน X ขณะที่อยู่
ใน state ที่อธิบายด้วย density matrix row แต่ละ outcome a ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ trace ของ PA คูณ
row กล่าวสั้นๆ สิ่งเดียวที่เปลี่ยนคือเรา relax เงื่อนไขบน matrices เหล่านี้ โดยเฉพาะ matrices
ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น projection matrices พวกมันแค่ต้องเป็น positive semi-definite และสอดคล้องกัน ฉันแทน Pi ด้วย P
เพราะ Pi เป็นชื่อ conventional สำหรับ projection ในขณะที่ฉันชอบใช้ P สำหรับ positive semi-definite
matrices นี่เป็น generalization ของ description ที่เรามีสำหรับ projective measurements โดยวิธีเพราะ projection matrices เป็น positive
semi-definite เสมอ และจริงๆ แล้วสามารถ define ได้อีกแบบว่าเป็น positive semi-definite matrices ที่ eigenvalues
สามารถเป็นได้แค่ศูนย์และหนึ่ง เราสังเกตได้ว่า definition นี้
สมเหตุสมผลในแง่ที่เราได้ probability vector สำหรับ outcome probabilities เสมอ ดังต่อไปนี้
ก่อนอื่น ตัวเลขที่ฉันเรียกว่า outcome probabilities เหล่านี้เป็น non-negative real numbers เสมอ นั่นก็เพราะ
ทั้ง PA และ row เป็น positive semi-definite และ trace ของ product ของ positive semi-definite สอง
matrices เป็น non-negative real number เสมอ และฉันจะปล่อยให้คุณคิดว่าทำไมถึงเป็นเช่นนั้น
และประการที่สอง ตัวเลขต้องรวมกันได้หนึ่งเพราะ trace เป็น linear function
matrices p 0 ถึง PN ลบ 1 ถูกกำหนดให้รวมกันได้ identity และ density matrices มี trace เท่ากับ
หนึ่ง ดังนั้นโดยไม่คำนึงถึง density matrix row ที่เราเริ่มต้น outcome probabilities จะสร้าง
probability vector เสมอ ตอนนี้ดูตัวอย่างบางส่วน ฉันพูดถึงแล้วว่า
projective measurements เป็น special case ของ general measurements เพราะ projections เป็น positive semi-definite เสมอ
แต่เริ่มแบบง่ายก็ดี ดังนั้นเริ่มด้วย standard basis measurement ของ qubit เราสามารถแสดง standard basis
measurement ของ qubit ด้วย matrices สองตัวคือ p 0 และ P1 ที่ define ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ p 0 คือ ket 0 bra 0 และ P1 คือ ket 1
bra 1 สิ่งเหล่านี้ล้วนเป็น positive semi-definite matrices และจริงๆ แล้วเป็น projections และรวมกันได้
identity อย่างชัดเจน ดังนั้นด้วยกันพวกมัน describe การวัด ถ้าเรา apply การวัดนี้กับ qubit
ใน state ที่อธิบายด้วย density matrix row ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcome zero ที่จะปรากฏคือ trace ของ p 0 คูณ row
และความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcome หนึ่งคือ trace ของ P1 คูณ row และโดย cyclic property ของ trace เราได้
diagonal entries สองตัวของ row ตามที่คาดไว้ นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างที่
ครั้งนี้ matrices ไม่ใช่ projections แต่เป็น positive semi-definite และบังเอิญเป็น density
matrices ด้วย แต่นั่นไม่สำคัญ แต่สิ่งที่สำคัญคือพวกมันรวมกันได้ identity ดังนั้นด้วยกันพวกมัน describe
การวัด เราสามารถเห็นสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อการวัดนี้ทำบน qubit ใน plus state ตัวอย่างเช่น แค่เพื่อ
ดูวิธีที่ทำงานสำหรับตัวอย่างหนึ่งของ state และการคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นแสดงบน
หน้าจอ สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่าแม้ plus state เป็น pure state และเราสามารถแสดง state นั้นด้วย quantum state vector ket plus เรา
ต้อง plug density matrix representation ของ state นั้น ซึ่งคือ ket plus bra plus เข้าไปใน formulas เพื่อได้
ความน่าจะเป็น และขอสังเกตด้วยว่าเพราะเรากำลังพูดถึง destructive measurement ไม่มี
specification ของ postmeasurement quantum state ของ qubit นี้ ดังนั้นทุกสิ่งที่เรามีคือ specification ของ outcome
probabilities นี่คือตัวอย่างสุดท้ายสำหรับตอนนี้ และมันน่าสนใจทีเดียว อีกครั้งมันเป็นการวัดของ
single qubit และเพื่อ describe มัน เราจะเริ่มด้วยการ define quantum state vectors สี่ตัวที่เรียกว่า tetrahedral
states และเหตุผลที่เรียก tetrahedral states ก็เพราะมันสอดคล้องกับ vertices ทั้งสี่ของ
regular tetrahedron ที่จารึกภายใน Bloch sphere และเพื่อความชัดเจนเมื่อเราบอกว่านี่เป็น regular tetrahedron
เราหมายถึง solid สี่ด้านที่แต่ละด้านเป็น equilateral triangle ดังนั้นมีความสมมาตรสมบูรณ์แบบที่นี่ ทุก
edge มีความยาวเท่ากัน และมุมที่สร้างระหว่าง adjacent edges สองอันใดๆ ก็เท่ากัน
และตอนนี้เราสามารถ define การวัดที่น่าสนใจที่มีสี่ outcomes ที่เป็นไปได้ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ หรือใน words เราสามารถ take
matrices ของเราเป็น density matrix representations ของ states เหล่านี้หารด้วยสอง ตอนนี้สิ่งเหล่านี้ positive
semi-definite matrices อย่างแน่นอนเพราะเป็น density matrices หารด้วยสอง และคุณสามารถตรวจสอบการคำนวณเพื่อ
ดูว่าพวกมันรวมกันได้ identity จริงๆ แต่อีกวิธีในการเห็นนั้นคือคิดเกี่ยวกับ symmetry ถ้าเรา average สี่ states
เหล่านี้ด้วยกัน เราได้ completely mixed state ซึ่งอยู่ที่ศูนย์กลางของ Bloch sphere แต่เพราะเรา
หารแต่ละอันด้วยสองแทนสี่ เราได้สองเท่าของ completely mixed state ซึ่งก็คือ identity ฉันจะไม่พูดอะไรเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับ
การวัดนี้ในตอนนี้ นอกจากสังเกตว่ามันไม่ใช่ projective measurement แต่เป็นตัวอย่างที่ดีและ
เราจะเห็นมันปรากฏขึ้นอีกในภายหลังในบทเรียน อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการอธิบาย general measurements คือเป็น channels ตามที่เราจะ
พูดถึงตอนนี้ แนวคิดที่นี่คือ classical probabilistic states สามารถแสดงด้วย diagonal density matrices ดังนั้น
เพราะ measurement outcomes เป็น classical เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับการวัดว่าเป็น channels ที่ output เป็น diagonal density
matrix เสมอที่อธิบาย measurement outcome ดังนั้นดูสิ่งนี้ในรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมอีกนิด ถ้าเราคิด
อย่าง abstract เกี่ยวกับ general measurement เราสามารถอธิบายการวัดนั้นเป็น channel fi input system สำหรับ channel คือ
ระบบ X ใดก็ตามที่กำลังวัด และ output system คือระบบ Y ที่ classical states สอดคล้องกับ
measurement outcomes ซึ่งเราถือว่าเป็น integers ตั้งแต่ 0 ถึง n ลบ 1 สำหรับ positive integer
M บางตัว และเพราะ measurement outcomes เป็น classical เราต้องการว่าสำหรับทุก input density matrix row สำหรับระบบ
X output fi ของ row ต้องเป็น diagonal density matrix ตัวอย่างเช่นถ้าเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
standard basis measurement ของ qubit และคิดเกี่ยวกับการวัดนั้นว่าอธิบายด้วย channel เราสามารถแสดงได้ตามที่มีที่นี่บนหน้าจอ
ถ้า input density matrix คือ row เราจะได้ outcome zero ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ bra 0 row ket zero
และเราจะได้ outcome หนึ่งด้วยความน่าจะเป็น bra one row ket one และดังนั้นถ้าเราแสดง
classical measurement outcomes เหล่านี้เป็น density matrices เราจะได้ expression นี้สำหรับ channel ที่สอดคล้องกัน และปรากฏว่า
มันไม่ใช่อะไรนอกจาก completely dephasing channel และสิ่งนั้นสอดคล้องกับแนวคิดที่ว่า completely dephasing
channel แสดง decoherence แบบ extreme ซึ่งอาจหมายความได้หลายอย่าง แต่เมื่อฉันใช้คำนั้นฉัน
กำลังพูดถึงแนวโน้มของ quantum states ที่จะกลายเป็น classical เพราะสิ่งแวดล้อมรอบระบบใดก็ตามที่เรา
พูดถึงกำลัง watching ในแง่หนึ่ง หรืออีกนัยหนึ่งกำลังวัด
ดังนั้น measurement outcomes สามารถอธิบายเป็น channels ตามที่ฉันเพิ่งอธิบาย แต่นี่ไม่ใช่แค่ความเป็นไปได้ มัน
characterization ของ general measurements และสิ่งที่ฉันหมายความว่าคือต่อไปนี้ แน่นอนมี channels
ที่ไม่แสดงการวัดเพราะ output อาจไม่เป็น diagonal density matrix เสมอ แต่ถ้า
output ของ channel เป็น diagonal density matrix เสมอไม่ว่าเราเลือก input state row อะไร ก็จำเป็นว่าสามารถ
แสดง channel นั้นในรูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอสำหรับการเลือกการวัดบางอย่าง ซึ่งหมายถึง collection ของ
positive semi-definite matrices ที่รวมกันได้ identity และนั่นดีสำหรับหลายเหตุผล รวมถึง fact ที่ว่า
โดยพื้นฐานบอกเราว่า definition ของการวัดเป็น collections ของ matrices นั้นไม่ได้ขาดหาย
อะไร อีกวิธีพูดก็คือวิธีคิดเกี่ยวกับการวัดเป็น channels นี้เป็น operational
หรืออาจเป็น axiomatic ในแง่ที่มันจับภาพสิ่งที่การวัดควรเป็น ซึ่งก็คือ physical process ที่
transform quantum information เป็น classical information และปรากฏว่ามันเทียบเท่าอย่างสมบูรณ์กับ description แรกของเรา
สำหรับการวัดซึ่งเป็น algebraic ล้วนๆ ฉันจะไม่อธิบาย proof ของความเทียบเท่าใน video นี้ แต่
มันไม่ยาก และถ้าสนใจสามารถหา proof ในเนื้อหาที่เป็นลายลักษณ์อักษรสำหรับบทเรียนซึ่ง link ใน video
description เราพูดถึงสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อ general measurement ทำบนระบบใน state ที่กำหนด
อย่างน้อยสำหรับกรณีของ destructive measurements ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง partial measurements หมายความว่า
แค่ส่วนหนึ่งของ compound system ถูกวัด เพื่อความแม่นยำ สมมติว่าเรามีคู่ระบบ XZ ที่
อยู่ด้วยกันใน state ที่อธิบายด้วย density matrix row และการวัดที่อธิบายด้วย collection ของ positive semi-definite matrices ที่รวมกันได้
identity ทำบนระบบ X เพียงอย่างเดียว โดยธรรมชาติสิ่งนี้ส่งผลใน
measurement outcome และเพราะเรากำลังพูดถึง destructive measurements เราสามารถจินตนาการว่ากระบวนการวัดทำลายระบบ
X แต่เรายังมีระบบ Z ที่ต้องกังวล และเราต้องเข้าใจว่าการวัดของ X ส่งผลต่อ
state ของ Z อย่างไร ก่อนอื่นพูดถึง outcome
probabilities เพราะเรากำลังพูดถึงการวัดระบบ X เพียงอย่างเดียว ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ
outcomes ที่ต่างกันที่จะปรากฏสามารถขึ้นอยู่กับ state ของ X เพียงอย่างเดียวเท่านั้น กล่าวคือขึ้นอยู่กับ
reduced state ของ X เท่านั้น โดยเฉพาะความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcome a ที่กำหนดที่จะปรากฏถูกให้โดย
formula เดิมจากก่อนหน้า ซึ่งก็คือ trace ของ PA คูณ reduced state ของ X ซึ่งเราเรียกว่า row
subX state row subX ได้มาจาก row โดยการ trace out Z ดังนั้นเราสามารถทำ
substitution นั้น และแม้ว่าอาจไม่ชัดเจนทันที equation ที่ได้สามารถเขียนได้อีกแบบตามที่
แสดงบนหน้าจอ มันคือ trace ของ PA tensored กับ identity matrix บนระบบ Z คูณ
row ตอนนี้นั่นเป็น equality ที่คุ้มค่าที่จะใช้เวลาตรวจสอบ มัน intuitive เราไม่ได้ทำ
อะไรเลยกับ Z ดังนั้นมันสมเหตุสมผลที่ identity บน Z จะปรากฏแบบนี้ แต่ยังสามารถตรวจสอบ
algebraically และฉันจะปล่อยให้คุณทำพร้อมกับข้อแนะนำที่จะพิจารณากรณีก่อนที่ row เป็น tensor product ของ matrices สองตัวแล้ว
ใช้ linearity สรุปว่ามันต้องใช้ได้กับ row ทั้งหมด และฉันจะบอกด้วยว่ามันไม่ขึ้นอยู่กับ fact ที่ว่า PA
เป็น positive semi-definite หรือ row เป็น density matrix นี่เป็น equality ที่จะใช้ได้สำหรับการเลือก
matrices ใดๆ แทน PA และ row ตราบเท่าที่มี dimensions ที่ถูกต้องสำหรับ expression ที่จะ make
sense และตอนนี้ดูว่า state ของ Z ได้รับผลกระทบจากการวัดอย่างไร และแนวทางธรรมชาติใน
มุมมองของฉันคือคิดเกี่ยวกับการวัดเป็น channel นี่คือ channel ที่เราเชื่อมโยงกับการวัดของเรา และเรา
คิดเกี่ยวกับมันเป็น channel จากระบบ X ไปยังระบบ Y ใหม่ที่ classical states สอดคล้องกับ measurement outcomes ดังนั้นใน formula
นี้ Sigma แสดง state ของระบบ X เพียงอย่างเดียว ถ้าเรา apply channel นี้กับ
ระบบ X ในขณะที่คู่ XZ อยู่ใน state row เราจะได้ density matrix ที่เรามีที่นี่ อีกครั้ง
ใช้เวลาเท่าที่ต้องการในการตรวจสอบสิ่งนี้ และข้อแนะนำของฉันอีกครั้งคือพิจารณากรณีก่อนที่ row เป็น tensor
product ของ matrices สองตัวแล้วใช้ linearity ตอนนี้เราเห็น state ชนิดนี้
ที่ first system เป็น classical และ second system เป็น quantum เป็นตัวอย่างในบทเรียน density matrix
แต่ละ a เกิดขึ้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็นบางอย่าง และนั่นคือ trace ของ second tensor factor ดังนั้นคุณสามารถคิด
เกี่ยวกับ second tensor factors เหล่านี้ว่าเป็น density matrices คูณด้วยความน่าจะเป็น ดังนั้นเพื่อให้ได้ state ของ
Z conditioned บนการได้ measurement outcome a หนึ่งๆ เราเพียงหาร probability ออก หรืออีกนัยหนึ่งเรา
normalize second tensor factor โดยหารด้วย trace ของมันเอง ดังนั้นสรุปถ้าเรา perform
การวัดบน X ในขณะที่คู่ XZ อยู่ใน state row นี่คือสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้น ก่อนอื่นแต่ละ outcome a ปรากฏ
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ trace ของ PA tensored กับ identity คูณ row และประการที่สอง conditioned บนการได้
measurement outcome a หนึ่งๆ state ของ Z ถูกให้โดย expression ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งคือสิ่งที่เราได้
จากการ normalize matrix ที่เพิ่งเห็นสักครู่ และนั่นเหมือนกับการหาร matrix ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
สำหรับ a ที่จะปรากฏ ควรบอกว่านี่ make sense ก็ต่อเมื่อความน่าจะเป็นไม่เป็นศูนย์เพราะมิฉะนั้นเรา
หารด้วยศูนย์ แต่ไม่เป็นไรเพราะเราไม่ต้องกังวลกับสิ่งที่ไม่เกิดขึ้นในส่วนนี้ของ
บทเรียน เราจะพูดถึง theorem ที่เรียบง่ายแต่พื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับการวัดที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ Naimark's
theorem กล่าวสั้นๆ สิ่งที่มันบอกคือการวัดใดๆ สามารถ implement ได้ตามที่รูปบนหน้าจอ
แนะนำ พูดในรูปของ words general measurement ที่กำหนดบนระบบ X สามารถ implement ได้ดังต่อไปนี้
เราก่อนอื่น introduce initialized workspace system Y ที่ classical states เป็น measurement outcomes ที่เป็นไปได้ ซึ่งเราสมมติว่า
numbered 0 ถึง n ลบ 1 จากนั้น unitary operation U ทำบนคู่
YX และจากนั้น standard basis measurement ทำบน Y ดังนั้นทุกอย่างโดยพื้นฐาน
ตายตัวแล้วนอกจากการเลือก U และสิ่งที่ theorem บอกคือจริงๆ แล้วเป็นไปได้ที่จะเลือก unitary
operation U เพื่อให้ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcomes ต่างๆ เห็นด้วยกับ general measurement ที่กำหนดเสมอ
ตอนนี้ดูวิธีที่ Naimark's theorem ถูกพิสูจน์ และมันไม่ยาก เราแค่ต้องทำ choice ที่ดีสำหรับ
unitary operation U และตรวจสอบว่ามันทำงาน แต่ก่อนอื่นเราต้องการ basic fact
จาก matrix theory ซึ่งก็คือสำหรับ positive semi-definite matrix P ใดๆ มีเสมอ unique positive semi-definite
matrix Q เช่นว่า Q กำลังสองเท่ากับ P โดยทั่วไปอาจมี matrices หลายตัวที่กำลังสองแล้วได้ P แต่
มีแค่หนึ่งตัวที่เป็น positive semi-definite notation ที่ใช้เรียก matrix นี้คือ square root ของ
P และนั่นก็คือวิธีที่เราเรียกใน words ถ้าต้องการคำนวณ square root ของ P สำหรับ positive
semi-definite matrix P บางตัวโดยวิธี คุณสามารถทำได้โดยคำนวณ spectral decomposition ของ P ก่อนแล้ว
แทน eigenvalues แต่ละตัวด้วย square root ของมันและปล่อย eigenvectors ไว้ eigenvalues ล้วนเป็น non-
negative ดังนั้นนี่ make sense และค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะเห็นว่า matrix ที่ได้จริงๆ เป็น positive semi-definite
และกำลังสองแล้วได้ P fact ที่ว่ามัน unique เป็นเรื่องต่างหาก มันไม่ยาก
ในการพิสูจน์โดยใช้ basic facts บางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ matrices แต่มันค่อนข้าง tangential กับบทเรียนและเราจะ take ส่วนนั้น
ว่าเป็นที่กำหนด และตอนนี้ที่เรามีแนวคิดนั้นในมือ มันค่อนข้างง่ายในการระบุ
unitary operation U ที่ทำงาน unitary matrix ใดๆ ที่ match pattern ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอจะ
ทำงานจริงๆ n columns แรกสมมติว่า X มี n classical states เช่นเดิม ได้มาจากการ stack square roots ของ
matrices ที่ describe การวัดซ้อนกัน และ columns ที่เหลือสามารถเป็นอะไรก็ได้ที่เรา
ต้องการ ไม่สร้างความแตกต่างใดๆ ตราบเท่าที่ matrix ทั้งหมดเป็น unitary
และโดยวิธีถ้าสังเกตเห็นความคล้ายคลึงกับความเชื่อมโยงระหว่าง Kraus และ Stinespring representations ของ channels นั่นไม่ใช่เรื่องบังเอิญ และ
จริงๆ แล้วสิ่งที่เรามีที่นี่โดยพื้นฐานคือ special case ของนั้นที่ Kraus matrices ทั้งหมดของเรา positive
semi-definite ดังนั้นมีสองสิ่งที่เราต้องตรวจสอบ สิ่งแรกคือการเลือก U นี้ทำงานจริงๆ และ
สิ่งที่สองคือเป็นไปได้ที่จะเลือก columns ที่ไม่ระบุในแบบที่ทำให้ U เป็น unitary ดังนั้นเริ่มด้วยสิ่ง
แรก นี่คือ state ที่เราเริ่มด้วย bottom system Y ถูก initialize ไปที่ zero state ในขณะที่ top system
เริ่มใน state row และจากนั้นเรา perform U ซึ่งหมายความว่าเรา conjugate ด้วย
U เราสามารถเขียนทั้งหมดนี้ในรูปของ block matrices ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เรามี U ทางซ้าย U dagger ทาง
ขวา และ ket zero bra zero tensored กับ row ตรงกลาง ซึ่งอยู่ในรูปแบบที่เรามีที่นี่ โดยมี row อยู่ใน
upper left hand corner และศูนย์ทุกที่อื่น และถ้าคิดเกี่ยวกับ product นี้สักครู่ มันชัดเจนว่า
entries ที่ไม่ระบุของ U ไม่สำคัญเลย เพราะมันถูกคูณด้วย zero entries ของ matrix
นี้เสมอ และถ้าเราทำการคูณผ่าน สิ่งที่ได้คือ
matrix ที่แสดงที่นี่ อธิบายเป็น block matrix หรืออีกทางหนึ่งเราสามารถแสดงโดยใช้ direct notation
แบบนี้ ซึ่งจริงๆ เป็นรูปแบบที่สะดวกกว่าสำหรับเรา ดังนั้นโฟกัสที่
expression นี้ และเพื่อความสะดวก ตั้งชื่อ matrix นี้ซึ่งเป็น density matrix ว่า
Sigma ขั้นตอนสุดท้ายคือ standard basis measurement บน Y ดังนั้น calculate reduced state ใน Y และ
นั่นง่ายมากให้ expression ที่เรามี เราแค่ trace out X ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับ second tensor
factor ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcome a ที่กำหนดที่จะปรากฏคือ diagonal entry ที่สอดคล้องกับ a เราสามารถเขียน
ได้แบบนี้ และมันเท่ากับ trace ของ square root ของ PA คูณ row คูณ square
root ของ PA และโดย cyclic property ของ trace เราได้ trace ของ PA คูณ row
ซึ่งคือสิ่งที่เราหวัง ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ outcomes ต่างๆ ที่จะปรากฏถูกต้อง พวกมันตรงกับ
การวัดต้นฉบับที่เราเริ่มต้นเสมอ สิ่งที่สองที่ต้องตรวจสอบ
คือเป็นไปได้ที่จะเติม columns ที่ไม่ระบุของ U ในแบบที่ทำให้มัน
unitary สิ่งนี้ตามมาจาก fact ที่ว่า n columns แรก ซึ่งเป็นอันที่สร้างโดย square roots ของ matrices ที่ describe
การวัด เป็น orthonormal และสามารถตรวจสอบค่อนข้างตรง รายละเอียดที่เกี่ยวข้องอยู่ที่นี่
บนหน้าจอ ดังนั้น pause video และใช้เวลาสักครู่คิดเกี่ยวกับนั้นถ้าต้องการ แต่ตามที่ฉันแนะนำก่อนหน้า
มันจริงๆ เป็น special case ของสิ่งที่เราพบในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า และนั่นคือ
proof จนถึงตอนนี้ในบทเรียน เราโฟกัสที่ destructive measurements หมายความว่าไม่มีการระบุ
postmeasurement quantum state ของระบบที่วัด สำหรับ non-destructive measurement ในทางกลับกัน มี
ไม่เพียงแค่ classical measurement outcome แต่ยังมี postmeasurement quantum state ของระบบที่วัด และ
ตามที่เราจะเห็น มีความเชื่อมโยงธรรมชาติกับ Naimark's theorem มีจริงๆ หลายวิธีในการ formulate non-destructive
measurements ในรูปแบบคณิตศาสตร์ แต่เราจะเริ่มด้วย formulation หนึ่งที่โดยพื้นฐานมาจาก Naimark's
theorem โดยตรง พิจารณา general measurement หมายความว่า destructive อีกแบบ ที่อธิบายด้วย collection ของ positive semi-definite
matrices p 0 ถึง PN ลบ 1 ที่รวมกันได้ identity เราสามารถ turn สิ่ง
นี้ให้เป็น non-destructive measurement ได้ง่ายๆ โดยพิจารณา implementation ของการวัดนี้ที่เราพูดถึงในบริบทของ Naimark's
theorem เรา introduce ระบบ Y ใหม่ interact มันกับ X ผ่าน unitary operation U และจากนั้น perform standard
basis measurement บน Y ดังนั้นระบบ X ยังอยู่ที่นั่น และเราสามารถพิจารณา
state ของมัน และจากการวิเคราะห์ที่เราผ่านมา เราสามารถกำหนดว่า postmeasurement state ของ X conditioned
บนการได้ measurement outcome a หนึ่งๆ ถูกให้โดย density matrix ที่ดู
แบบนี้ ใน words เรา conjugate ด้วย square root ของ measurement matrix ที่สอดคล้องกันแล้ว
normalize อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการ formulate non-destructive measurements ซึ่ง general กว่าคือในรูปของ Kraus
matrices ของ channels และนี่คือ definition ของการวัดที่คุณจะพบในตำราที่รู้จักกันดีของ Nielsen และ
Chuang ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติว่า m0 ถึง mM ลบ 1 เป็น square matrices ที่ satisfy
equation ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งหมายความว่าเราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ matrices เหล่านี้ว่าเป็น Kraus matrices ที่ describe
channel จริงๆ matrices เหล่านี้ describe channel แต่พวกมันยัง describe non-destructive measurement
ด้วย และวิธีที่ทำงานเมื่อระบบใน state row ที่กำหนดถูกวัดคือ ก่อนอื่น outcome probabilities
ถูกให้โดย equation ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ แต่ละ outcome ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ trace ของ ma คูณ
row คูณ ma dagger และ conditioned บน outcome a ที่ปรากฏ state ของระบบที่วัด
ดูแบบนี้ non-destructive measurements แบบนี้สามารถ implement ได้ใน
วิธีที่คล้ายกับที่เรามีสำหรับ Naimark's theorem และฉันจะปล่อยให้คุณคิดเรื่องนั้น
ถ้าต้องการ เป็นไปได้ที่จะ generalize แนวคิดของ non-destructive measurement ยิ่งกว่านี้อีก ตัวอย่างเช่น
มีแนวคิดของ quantum instrument ที่บางครั้งมีประโยชน์มาก แต่ฉันจะไม่ cover สิ่งนั้นใน
video นี้ ในช่วงสุดท้ายของบทเรียน ฉันจะพูดถึงสั้นๆ เกี่ยวกับ tasks สองอย่างที่เกี่ยวข้องกับการวัด ได้แก่ quantum state discrimination และ quantum state
tomography มีอะไรอีกมากมายที่จะพูดเกี่ยวกับทั้งสอง concepts เหล่านี้ และเรากำลัง scratch
surface จริงๆ ดังนั้นเริ่มด้วยการชี้แจงสิ่งที่คำเหล่านี้หมายถึงและวิธีที่พวกมันต่างกัน
ก่อนอื่นคือ quantum state discrimination แนวคิดที่นี่คือเรามี collection ที่รู้จักของ quantum
states ของระบบบางตัวพร้อมกับความน่าจะเป็นที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ states เหล่านี้ ดังนั้นเพื่อความแม่นยำ สมมติ
ว่า row 0 ถึง row M ลบ 1 เป็น density matrices แสดง quantum states ที่เป็นไปได้ของระบบ X และ p 0
ถึง pN ลบ 1 เป็นความน่าจะเป็นที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ states เหล่านี้ ดังนั้นถ้าเรารวมความน่าจะเป็นเป็น single
vector เราได้ probability vector วิธีพูดที่กระชับ ก็คือเรามี ensemble ของ quantum
states และตอนนี้ abstract way ที่เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ quantum state discrimination เป็น task หรือเป็น problem
คือ ก่อนอื่นตัวเลขระหว่าง 0 ถึง N ลบ 1 ถูกเลือกแบบสุ่มตามความน่าจะเป็น จากนั้นระบบ X
ถูก prepare ใน state ที่สอดคล้องกับตัวเลขที่เลือกแบบสุ่ม และเป้าหมายคือกำหนดโดย
การวัดของ X ว่าตัวเลขไหนถูกเลือก ดังนั้นเรามี finite number ของ
alternatives พร้อมกับ prior และเป้าหมายคือกำหนดว่า alternative ไหนเกิดขึ้นจริง สำหรับบาง choices ของ states และ
ความน่าจะเป็น สิ่งนี้อาจง่าย และสำหรับอื่นๆ อาจไม่เป็นไปได้ที่จะทำโดยไม่มีโอกาสทำผิด
และมีคำถามเฉพาะต่างๆ ที่เราสามารถถามได้ เช่น ความน่าจะเป็นขั้นต่ำของการทำผิดคืออะไร
และการวัดที่ achieve ความน่าจะเป็นขั้นต่ำของ error นี้หน้าตาอย่างไร quantum state tomography ใน
ทางกลับกันต่างออกไป ที่นี่เรามี quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จักของระบบ ดังนั้น
โดยทั่วไปไม่มี prior หรือข้อมูลใดๆ เกี่ยวกับ alternatives ที่เป็นไปได้ แต่ครั้งนี้ไม่ใช่ copy เดียวของ state ที่
ให้ แต่มี copies อิสระหลายอัน ซึ่งหมายความว่าสำหรับจำนวน n ที่อาจใหญ่
เรามีระบบ n ตัวที่เหมือนกัน X1 ถึง xn ที่แต่ละตัวถูก prepare อิสระใน state
row และครั้งนี้เป้าหมายคือหา approximation ของ quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จักนี้เป็น density matrix โดยการวัด
ระบบ ดังนั้นสรุปใน quantum state discrimination เรามี single copy ของ
state และพยายาม discriminate ระหว่าง finite number ของ alternatives ที่รู้จัก และใน quantum state tomography เรามีหลาย independent
copies ของ quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จัก และเป้าหมายคือหา description ของ state นั้น หรืออย่างน้อย approximation ที่ดีของ
มัน quantum state discrimination น่าสนใจเพราะมัน abstract ชนิดของสถานการณ์ที่มักเกิดขึ้นใน
computation และ cryptography ตัวอย่างเช่น ที่ alternative หนึ่งจาก finite set ของความเป็นไปได้เกิดขึ้นและเราหรือคนอื่น
กำลังพยายามหาว่ามันคืออะไรโดยการวัด quantum system กรณีที่ง่ายที่สุดที่ไม่ trivial คือ
ที่มีแค่สอง alternatives ซึ่งหมายความว่า M เท่ากับสอง ดังนั้น task คือ discriminate ระหว่างคู่
ของ states กรณีนี้ปรากฏว่าโดยพื้นฐานเป็นปัญหาที่แก้ได้สมบูรณ์ สมมติว่าเป้าหมายคือ minimize
โอกาสของการ discriminate ผิด มีการเลือกที่ optimal สำหรับการวัดและมักเรียกว่า
Helstrom measurement มันเป็น projective measurement จริงๆ และสามารถอธิบายได้
ดังต่อไปนี้ ก่อนอื่นเราพิจารณา weighted difference ระหว่างสอง alternatives หมายความว่า p 0 คูณ row 0 ลบ P1 คูณ row one
ดังนั้นเรากำลังคูณความน่าจะเป็นของการ draw แต่ละ state สองตัวเหล่านี้กับ states เองและเรา take
ความต่าง นั่นเป็น Hermitian matrix เพราะมันเท่ากับ conjugate transpose ของตัวเอง ดังนั้นมัน
spectral decomposition และเราทราบโดยเฉพาะว่า eigenvalues ล้วนเป็น real numbers ดังนั้นสมมติว่าเรามี
spectral decomposition เขียนในรูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ สิ่งที่เราทำต่อไปคือรวบรวม
eigenvalues เป็นสอง sets ที่ positive eigenvalues ทั้งหมดอยู่ใน set หนึ่งและ negative eigenvalues ทั้งหมดอยู่ใน
อีก set เพื่อความแม่นยำ ให้ S0 เป็น set ของ indices k ทั้งหมดที่ eigenvalue Lambda K ที่สอดคล้องกัน
เป็น non-negative และให้ S1 เป็น indices ที่เหลือซึ่งเป็นอันที่สอดคล้องกับ negative eigen
values มันไม่สำคัญจริงๆ ว่า set ไหนมี indices ที่สอดคล้องกับ zero eigenvalues ที่นี่ เรากำลังทำ
arbitrary choice ที่จะรวมใน S0 แต่ไม่ต่างหากบางส่วนหรือทั้งหมดถูกรวมใน S1 แทน สิ่งที่สำคัญจริงๆ คือ
เรากำลังแยก positive และ negative eigenvalues และสุดท้ายเรา define projections Pi สอง
อัน Pi 0 และ Pi 1 ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ใน words Pi 0 เป็น projection onto
subspace ที่ span โดย eigenvectors ที่สอดคล้องกับ non-negative eigenvalues และ Pi 1 เป็น projection onto space
ที่ span โดย eigenvectors ที่สอดคล้องกับ negative eigenvalues สิ่งเหล่านี้เป็น projections จริงๆ และ
ถ้าเราบวกพวกมันเข้าด้วยกัน เราได้ identity matrix เพราะ eigenvectors S 0 ถึง S N ลบ 1 สร้าง
orthonormal basis ถ้าการวัดนี้ถูก perform ในสถานการณ์ที่อยู่ ซึ่งหมายความว่า
state ที่กำลังวัดคือ row 0 ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น p 0 และ row one ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น P1 ปรากฏว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นของการ identification ที่ถูกต้องมี formula ที่ค่อนข้างง่ายในรูปของ eigenvalues Lambda 0 ถึง Lambda n ลบ
one ฉันจะไม่อธิบายรายละเอียดการคำนวณใน video นี้ คุณสามารถดูเนื้อหาที่เป็นลายลักษณ์อักษรที่ link ใน video description ถ้า
สนใจ หรือลองโน้มน้าวตัวเองว่า formula นี้ถูกต้อง เรายังสามารถแสดง
ความน่าจะเป็นนี้โดยใช้ matrix norm ที่เรียกกันทั่วไปว่า trace norm มัน notation ที่คล้ายกับ Euclidean norm สำหรับ vectors
ยกเว้นว่ามี subscript ของ 1 เพื่อบ่งชี้ว่าเป็น trace norm trace norm มีความสำคัญมากและ
พบบ่อยมากใน quantum computing แต่ฉันจะไม่พูดอะไรมากเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับมันในบทเรียนนี้ วิธีหนึ่งในการ
define มันสำหรับ Hermitian matrices คือมันเป็นผลรวมของ absolute values ของ eigenvalues ดังนั้นคุณสามารถคิด
เกี่ยวกับ equality ที่สองนี้ว่าตามมาจาก definition นั้นโดยตรง trace norm ยังสามารถ
define ได้ในวิธีอื่นๆ ที่ general กว่า และเราจะพบ trace norm อีกครั้งในบทเรียนถัดไป นี่จริงๆ
คือสิ่งที่ดีที่สุดที่คุณทำได้ การวัดนี้ optimal สมมติว่าเป้าหมายของคุณคือ maximize โอกาสของการ
guess ที่ถูกต้อง fact นั้นบางครั้งเรียกว่า Helstrom-Holevo theorem และบางครั้งก็เรียกว่า Helstrom's
theorem ดังนั้นคุณไม่สามารถ beat การวัดนี้ในแง่ของ correctness probability และมันดีเพราะ
มี recipe ง่ายๆ สำหรับการวัดเองและ formula ที่แน่นอนสำหรับ correctness probability ในรูปของ trace
norm trace norm มักใช้เป็นวิธีวัดความแตกต่างที่สังเกตได้ระหว่าง density matrices สำหรับ
เหตุผลนี้โดยเฉพาะ และเมื่อผู้คนพูดถึง trace distance ระหว่าง states พวกเขามักหมายถึง
ครึ่งหนึ่งคูณ trace norm ของความต่างระหว่าง density matrices สองตัว ซึ่งที่นี่สอดคล้องกับกรณีที่ p 0 และ P1 เป็น 1/2 ทั้งคู่ ซึ่ง
เป็นกรณีธรรมชาติที่จะพิจารณา quantum state discrimination สำหรับสอง states แก้ได้อย่าง optimal โดย
Helstrom measurement ซึ่งเรามี recipe ง่ายๆ และ formula ง่ายๆ สำหรับ correctness
probability ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อเราต้องการ discriminate ระหว่างสามหรือมาก states กว่านั้น ในกรณีนี้เราไม่มี
formula โดยทั่วไปสำหรับการเลือก optimal ของการวัดหรือ expression ง่ายๆ สำหรับ maximum probability ของ
correctness อย่างไรก็ตามเป็นไปได้ที่จะหา approximation ที่ดีของ optimal measurement ด้วยความช่วยเหลือของคอมพิวเตอร์
และโดยเฉพาะสามารถทำได้โดยใช้เทคนิค optimization ที่น่าสนใจและทรงพลังมากที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ semidefinite programming แต่ไม่ใช่
สิ่งที่คุณสามารถ implement ได้โดยใช้ดินสอและกระดาษตัวอย่างเช่น ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าคนบาง
คนให้ description ของการวัดและอ้างว่าการวัดนั้น optimal สำหรับ quantum state discrimination task แล้ว
จริงๆ แล้วง่ายมากที่จะ verify หรือ falsify ข้ออ้างนั้น และสามารถทำได้โดยใช้ Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax conditions ฉันจะไม่อธิบายว่ามันคืออะไรใน video นี้ แต่มันเป็น conditions ง่ายๆ และมันค่อนข้าง cool
ที่สิ่งนี้เป็นไปได้ นี่คือตัวอย่างที่เชื่อมกลับไปยัง tetrahedral states
ที่เราเห็นก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน สมมติว่าเราได้รับหนึ่งใน four states เหล่านี้ที่เลือกแบบสุ่ม
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/4 สำหรับแต่ละอัน และเป้าหมายของเราคือกำหนดว่าเราได้รับ state ไหน ไม่น่าแปลกใจ
การเลือกที่ดีที่สุดที่คุณทำได้สำหรับการวัดเพื่อทำสิ่งนี้คือ tetrahedral measurement คุณไม่สามารถทำ
สิ่งนี้ได้เสมอสำหรับ collection ของ pure states arbitrary แต่เนื่องจาก symmetries ที่เกี่ยวข้องที่นี่ สิ่งนี้
ทำงาน และเราได้การวัดที่ valid จริงๆ และผ่าน Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax conditions ที่ฉันพูดถึง
เมื่อสักครู่ ปรากฏว่าค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาที่จะพิสูจน์ว่านี่เป็นการเลือกที่ optimal ของ
การวัด โดยเฉพาะสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นที่นี่คือการวัดถูกต้องเสมอด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 ซึ่ง
ไม่เลว เพราะมีสี่ alternatives ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นของการ guess ที่ถูกต้องสองเท่าของการ guess แบบสุ่ม และ
บังเอิญเป็นสิ่งที่ดีที่สุดที่คุณทำได้สำหรับ states เหล่านี้ ตอนนี้ฉันจะพูดอีกนิดหน่อยเกี่ยวกับ quantum state tomography
ที่เรามี copies อิสระหลายอันของ quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จัก และเป้าหมายคือหา approximation ของ density matrix ที่อธิบาย
state นั้น จริงๆ มี variants ต่างๆ ของปัญหานี้ที่ขึ้นอยู่กับ assumptions ของคุณ และใน
โดยเฉพาะบน measurements ชนิดใดที่คุณอนุญาต ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถกำหนดให้แต่ละระบบวัดแยกกัน และ
ผลลัพธ์ถูกรวมกันบางแบบเพื่อให้ได้ description ของ density matrix หรือเราสามารถอนุญาตให้ทุก
ระบบวัดด้วยกันเป็น single compound system ซึ่งดีกว่ามากในทางทฤษฎี แต่ยังต้องการมากกว่า
จาก standpoint ทางเทคโนโลยี นอกจาก choices ที่ทำสำหรับการวัด ยังมี
consideration สำคัญซึ่งก็คือวิธี reconstruct description ของ density matrix จากข้อมูลใดก็ตามที่
ได้จากการวัด ฉันจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดเรื่องนี้ จุดของฉันก็แค่แนะนำ
ว่า quantum state tomography จริงๆ แล้วเป็น umbrella concept ที่มี variants มากมายมากกว่าการเป็น
single procedure มีการวิจัยมากมายเกี่ยวกับปัญหานี้ รวมถึงบาง breakthrough results ที่ค่อนข้าง
ล่าสุดที่เชื่อมจำนวน copies n กับความแม่นยำของ approximation ที่สามารถได้ และมันยังคงเป็น
interesting และ active area ของการวิจัย เพื่อ finish บทเรียน ดู quantum state tomography
สำหรับ qubits และวิธีที่เราสามารถทำได้ ดังนั้นสมมติว่า row เป็น density matrix แสดง state ของ
single qubit และ X1 ถึง xn เป็น qubits ที่ล้วน prepare อิสระใน state row และสำหรับ
การพูดถึงนี้ สมมติว่า n ใหญ่ สิ่งที่เราสามารถทำได้คือแบ่ง
ระบบเป็นสาม piles ที่เกือบเท่ากัน และสำหรับ pile แรกเราจะ perform การวัดในรูปของ plus
minus basis สำหรับแต่ละ outcome ที่สอดคล้องกับ plus เราจะได้ score plus one และสำหรับแต่ละ
outcome ที่สอดคล้องกับ minus เราจะได้ score minus one วิธีที่กระชับกว่าในการอธิบายการวัด
นี้คือมันเป็น Pauli X measurement เพราะ plus และ minus states เป็น eigenvectors ของ Pauli X matrix และ
eigenvalues ที่สอดคล้องกันคือ plus one และ minus one และจริงๆ แล้วนั่นยังเป็นวิธีที่พบบ่อยกว่ามากในการอธิบายมัน และ
จริงๆ แล้ว expected value ของ score เท่ากับ trace ของ Sigma x คูณ row ตอนนี้เราไม่จำเป็นต้องรู้ว่า
expected value นี้คืออะไร แต่ถ้าเรา average scores ที่ได้จาก trials มากมาย เราน่าจะได้
approximation ที่ดีของ expected value นี้โดย law of large numbers และมีบาง statistical bounds ที่รู้จักกันดีที่เราสามารถใช้กับ
สิ่งนี้ถ้าต้องการเป็น quantitative มากขึ้นเกี่ยวกับ statement นั้น เราทำสิ่งที่คล้ายกันกับ Sigma y กับ second third ของ
ระบบ สิ่งเดียวที่เปลี่ยนที่นี่คือเราใช้ plus i และ minus i states ซึ่งเป็น eigenvectors ของ Sigma
Y และในทำนองเดียวกันสำหรับ Sigma Z ที่ standard basis vectors เป็น eigen
vectors และสุดท้ายเราสามารถใช้ formula ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ซึ่งบอกว่า coefficients ควรเป็นอะไร
ถ้า row เขียนเป็น linear combination ของ Pauli matrices และโดยการแทน approximations สำหรับ coefficients เหล่านี้
และอาจปรับนิดหน่อยเพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าเราได้ positive semi-definite matrix เราได้ approximation ของ
row แน่นอนมีรายละเอียดที่ฉันไม่ได้ลงไป เช่น ความแม่นยำของ approximation และระดับของ
confidence ที่เราสามารถหวังได้ แต่หวังว่านั่นให้แนวคิดพื้นฐานของวิธีหนึ่งที่ tomography สามารถทำบน
qubit ยังเป็นไปได้ที่จะทำ qubit tomography โดยใช้ tetrahedral measurement และจริงๆ แล้วสิ่งนี้ปรากฏว่า
ค่อนข้างเรียบง่ายและหรูหราอย่างน้อยในรูปแบบคณิตศาสตร์ สิ่งที่เราสามารถทำได้คือ perform แค่
การวัดเดียวนี้บน independent copies ทั้งหมดของ quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จักของเรา และโดยใช้
remarkable formula ที่แสดงที่นี่ เราสามารถหา approximation ของ state ของเราโดย estimate trace ของ PK คูณ
row สำหรับแต่ละ K จาก fraction ของครั้งที่ measurement outcome ที่สอดคล้องกันปรากฏ อีกครั้ง สิ่งนี้ทำงานได้เฉพาะเพราะ
symmetries สมบูรณ์แบบที่เรามีระหว่าง four states เหล่านี้ และจริงๆ แล้วมีปัญหาที่น่าสนใจที่ยังไม่แก้ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ generalizations
ของแนวทางนี้ไปยังระบบที่ใหญ่กว่า และนั่นเป็นสถานที่ที่ดีที่จะหยุดบทเรียน ขอบคุณสำหรับการรับชม และฉัน
หวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วมกับฉันในบทเรียนถัดไปซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ purifications และ Fidelity สวัสดี